heading into a meeting with prosecutors
before his arrest presidential hopeful
felix maritiago was defiant
saying he dedicated his life to the
pursuit of freedom
and wouldn't back down despite
everything that may come our way
the regime is the true minority compared
to a nation that wants work
a nation that wants freedom peace and
justice
and that's what we're doing mariaga is
accused of terrorism
and backing international sanctions
against the nicaraguan government
but his supporters say the allegations
are part of an intensifying crackdown on
dissent
and efforts by president daniel ortega
to eliminate
any challenges for his office
maradiago's lawyer says the opposition
politician has been beaten in custody
a strong blow with a fist in the face
then another blow two blows in
marijuaga's face
and as well as that there are the acts
of aggression carried out by the police
when they were taking us out of the
vehicles maradiago is the fourth
potential presidential candidate to be
detained in recent days
on tuesday police also arrested juan
sebastian chamorro
who in february accused police of using
surveillance to intimidate him
last week his cousin cristiano chamorro
was put under house arrest
just hours after she announced plans to
run against the president in november's
election
it sparked protests outside her home
last month her brother's independent
news outlet
was raided by police another candidate
arturo cruz was detained on saturday
for allegedly conspiring against
nicaraguan society
the detentions are being called a clear
infringement of the freedom of
expression
all of this is a desperate attempt by
the dictatorship to make us give up the
electoral road to peacefully resolve
this deep economic
and social crisis that they themselves
have provoked
the chamorro family is deeply entwined
in daniel ortega's political career
christiana's mother violetta became
president in 1990
ousting ortega after his first stint in
power
since his return to office in 2007
rights groups have accused president
ortega of authoritarian rule
and leading the brutal suppression of
anti-government protests in 2018
in which more than 300 people were
killed
ortega and his allies say they're
defending nicaragua's sovereignty
against hostile foreign influence and
sanctions
now protests are banned and most
opposition parties disqualified
ortega and his wife who's his vice
president have been sanctioned by the
u.s and the european union
the top u.s diplomat on latin america
julia chung has called for international
action
saying the latest arrests are further
proof of ortega's disregard for
democracy
alex o'brien al jazeera